pat oswalt
decided to spend his new year
and the following days
uh stabbing
his
friend of many decades dave chappelle
in the back
because dave chappelle did him a favor
and then pat oswalt got pushed back from
the liberal mob
and so pat and oswald decided to try to
throw his friend his much more talented
and famous friend over the over the side
of the boat
this was what started it all off was one
instagram post from pat oswalt
this was uh new year's day i think or
you know i think it was new year's day
it was finished my set at mack
hall and got a text from dave chappelle
come over to the arena he's performing
at next door and do a guest set why not
i wave goodbye to this hell year with a
genius i started comedy with 34 years
ago he works in arena like he's talking
to one person and charming their skin
off anyway i ended the year with a real
friend and a deep laugh can't ask for
much more and there's that picture of
dave chappelle and pat and oswald that's
really nice that's really nice you know
a nice grateful post from patton oswalt
tonight and dave chappelle did his
friend a favor and that's a lovely way
to spend the new year
except here's the problem
dave chappelle
sort of kind of like once or twice
contradicted the leftist orthodoxy
and patent oswalt is a leftist coward
two issues here he's a leftist he does
push left wing
ideas
and he's a coward before the mob and so
right away he publishes this essay
on instagram of him really thoughtfully
sitting at a pen and paper writing his
public apology to the mob
he says i saw a friend i hadn't seen in
a long time this new year's eve we've
known each other since we're teens he's
a fellow comedian the funniest i've ever
met i wanted to post a pic and an
instagram story about it so i did that
friend is dave chappelle 34 years we've
been friends he's refocused and refined
ideas a lot of us took as settled about
his race and history and life on planet
earth and spun them around with a fraser
punch line we've done bad and good gigs
open mics and tv tapings but we also 100
disagree about transgender rights and
representation so there it is there it
is right he's he's justifying seeing a
friend of 34 years
he's saying
look if we'd only been friends for 10
years maybe i wouldn't have said hello
but it was 34 years i had to i had to go
over
i don't even i don't even really like
the guy and he's like he's a good
comedian right he's funny and
ah but i had to and and but i'm sorry
but we disagree and he's a bigot and
he's a trans phobe and he's a bad person
and i'm a good person
we 100 disagree
about transgender rights and
representation i support trans people's
rights anyone's rights to live safely in
the world as their fullest selves for
all the things he's helped me evolve on
i'll always disagree with where he
stands now on transgender issues
but i also don't believe a seeker like
him has done evolving learning so it's
hey look my friend dave who i have to be
nice to because we've been friends for
34 years he's evil he's evil he's
totally evil i'm a good person but look
he's not
a hundred percent evil
he's still got a little glimmer of
potential goodness in him so i'm like
basically i'm just trying to help him be
a good person and you should really you
should be grateful to me
because i'm trying to help this evil man
reform
blah blah blah he goes on
he just goes on and babbles a little bit
more
this is really pathetic and
and and
mean and cruel and rude and all these
awful things to do to your and disloyal
and all
really terrible way to treat your friend
it's also dishonest because patent
oswald has for a long time made jokes
about transvestitism and sexually
confused people for instance
you said this is for like families and
kids
because this sounds really grim and
creepy well you didn't let me finish
because we're also going to have men in
bright clothing and makeup up time out
do you mean like
like transvestites right
well technically yes but they're going
to keep going so that they're clowns
you realize a clown is just a
transvestite that doesn't stop
like if you like if you
if you saw a guy in lipstick and i
should be like timmy leave him alone
that's his own thing the guy's like oh
no hang on
like oh timmy he's a wonderful clown get
over there
i didn't know you'd use a whole tube of
lipstick on one cheek please entertain
my child
run at him out of the darkness he'll
love it
so
the premise of the joke it's funny
enough joke premise of the joke is that
transgender people
are really just confused and the thing
that makes them transgender is that they
put on a lot of makeup
so if they put on a lot of makeup but
stop at a certain point then they're
called transvestites or transgender but
if they keep going the logical
conclusion of that will be that they're
a clown furthermore the other premise of
this joke is that if you see a
transvestite it would be natural to try
to keep your kid away from that
transvestite because the transvestite is
obviously a little bit confused on some
pretty important matters and so you just
say hey johnny don't maybe don't go over
there leave that person alone don't talk
to that person
right
but dave chappelle's a terrible person
because he said that men are not women
this is this is something
about these people
the
patent oswalts of the world the liz
cheney's of the world and the people who
take their side
that is
it it's the insult to the injury the
disloyalty
would be bad enough the cowardice would
be bad enough the ignorance and naivete
that if you just grovel to the mob they
won't attack you anymore which just
never actually happens if you just
apologize for something that you haven't
done wrong then maybe the mob will will
move on
but it's also the dishonesty they don't
believe this stuff
patton oswalt and dave chappelle i
seriously doubt disagree on the
transgender stuff what what pattern
oswald just said about transgenderism is
way more offensive than anything dave
chappelle has said
it's ju it's just the coward
it's just the going along to get along
hold up did you like that clip don't be
honest don't just flatter me
i hope you did if you did ring that bell
subscribe you'll get the notifications
if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there maybe leave a five star
review i don't know
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]